so Joey I got to ask who who are your
favorites all right I'm head
up um okay so the first one so the first
one I checked out was ASA coko mhm only
because you [__] love her I love and
she's [__] great I love her but then
I found in me caught on there oh she the
best doggo the best Dogo best dog I've
seen so many Clips she's funny she's so
[__] funny she's so cute she's so
[__] cute oh my God oh my God I want
to head p so bad oh the head patting
what I do I want to head P so I want I
want to reach into the screen so I can
give her a head pack cuz she's such a
good [__] is the only man
I'll and then recently I also got into
um this other V
called but I only love she's got like
the purple she's cat girl with purple
hair but I [__] love her because of
her voice she kind of has like a
tomboyish voice she kind of has like a s
[__] or Muki Voice who I [__] like you
know sties voice
she has that exact type of voice and I'm
I'm weak for that wait wait wait so if
you can understand both English and
Japanese fluent yeah which one what do
you mean like oh with vichu oh Japanese
for sure oh really yeah how come just
cuz I don't know the I don't know I'm
I'm a see you I have a see F sub is
better than
dub even even in v i don't know CU cuz
Joey leaves to an English speaking
country God it's just not the [__]
same D it jesz dub that [__] in Japanese
believe they dubb their own SS can you
believe that [__] yeah no because I'm
very much like a SE I have a SE fetish
like a voice fetish I do I do I love my
[__] seus and if there's like one
he's a SE simp I I'm a SE simp like you
know like anything that's voiced by like
sairo miuki or hanana I just immediately
[__] love because of the voice and I
feel with vtu is it's kind of the same
but like but that's the thing though I
found a few Hol live Japanese streamers
who I really like their voice but their
personal wasn't quite right for me so
it's just kind of finding that like
perfect combination of voice and
personality and for me the two the top
two right now are coron and uhok who
should I watch to get into it who would
you recommend I watch I will watch it
and I'll come back next what kind of
like content are you looking for because
it's there's so much is there is there a
mil vtuber cuz he
prob probably like your cuz we were me
me and Joey were playing this [__]
arcade game it's so [__] cool it's
like you get to pile it a [__]
so [__] badass and you have to pick
like your wifeu who always talks to you
when you tap your car there like six
different girls that you can choose from
like dude mil are always the hottest in
anime bro he picked the mil and I picked
the wall that's why you like Masterpiece
don't you so so I lock in I lock in you
know the beautiful older lady very nice
very nice and I I look her Joe which one
of you it's a [__]
10-year-old and like yay and I'm like oh
my [__] God she just t a lolly bro oh
my God it's the best oh my God also
Masterpiece is the best hentai yeah
we'll leave that for another episode too
many kid hent ties out there what you
enjoying streamers I should say CU it's
not just about the characters the
monkess right I I don't really enjoy
watching xqc but I love Tyler ju and I
feel like they're so like close in terms
of the kind of energy they have I don't
know like I definitely do think like
you're you're more into the kind of like
buff like yeah let's go kind of guys
like you love Tyler ju techon out boy
like I feel they kind of yeah I feel
like they're kind of in the same realm
right of like energy levels I love
watching small streams like people with
like four viewers right because you
always get the most like it's like you
you get to watch someone who's live
streaming who doesn't know how to live
stream and it's such an endearing way
when you watch like a 10-year-old
playing Minecraft and like they're
talking to the chat as they've like
learned from like ninja you know what I
mean so they're replicating a big
streamer's Behavior but like not quite
right and it's really like uncanny Valle
from the sound of that then I don't
think you can get into any H life V
considering that they're all pretty
[__] professional they're all big and
they're all professionals you might like
some smaller like Indie vtubers there
yeah like I saw I saw a few of them that
were like 2D and it was like 2D pieces
moving and it was really Jank and I was
like oh that's cute they oh they didn't
have enough money for the 3D one I guess
I I don't know I felt bad they just they
just using like face rig and [__] it was
like yeah it was like face rig but it
didn't work properly and I felt really
bad and I'm like oh man but it's really
endearing I really love like watching
viewers with they're like 20 30 because
they're kind of getting into the feel of
it but they're not quite there uh big
streamers yeah Tyler one's definitely my
favorite like even if I didn't like
League of Legends I think I'd just love
him like back when he was uh doing a
variety of streams he was amazing stuff
like I think the the life of tyan is one
of the best show me that one of the best
[__] YouTube videos out there that
had to be one of the like greatest
streams like wish
saw if you haven't watched this video
it's basically where he does like a
whole movie he reenacts it like a budget
mov live on stream that is that is like
one of my favorite streams of all time
that's that's the kind of streams I want
to do I want to do like events like like
kind of like I want to have a stream
where it's like turn up something dumb
is going to happen like please uh like I
want to do more of that cuz like the the
way I see vtubers is kind of like uh
variety TV for me cuz everyone's doing
something different like one of my one
of my favorite streamers to watch
because she just does some really random
[__] sometimes just aai or like yeah
yeah yeah and like what what got me into
her stuff is she's just like she's she's
just like pure chaos and degeneracy into
one right that sounds good I like that
so so this one time she was playing like
get over it or something and like and
like out of nowhere she just like smells
her feet because cuz they like they like
stink or something right and then
through that a meme started and then
what she did right after that it's like
one of the most cursed streams is that
she asks her viewers to send in feet
videos of just like people doing like
the the strangest things with feet and
then she reviews them and it's just it's
just equally as hilarious and cursed I
need to watch that that sounds
disgusting but really entertaining yeah
yeah and another one is that she starts
reviewing her own ludes right
so oh like Doin of her like like Ru 34s
yeah like rule 34s for her so she has
like several tiers of like less and she
has she she puts like this black bar
filter over like over like the pictures
so you can kind of see what's going on
and it's just the you're just watching
an anime girl review her own ludes and
I'm just like this is Peak content why
am I even trying like this this is this
is content you cannot find anywhere else
that is like more meta than
recreators can you send me a link to
this I'll watch it and then maybe I'll
come in next week and I'll be like I
want to take all my opinions back yeah
it's YouTubers are amazing yeah and it's
just like entertaining it's just stuff
that real streamers can't get away with
and then obviously you got like people
who are just really to get at video
games with with an Anime Avatar know but
then there are some that are just
[__] horrible at video games and they
just make it so [__] entertaining
because it takes them like six hours to
complete one level and they just
constantly just they're just trying
they're really just trying and
struggling and that [__] is just cute to
watch fair enough okay man all right I
I'll give it a shot I mean I do want to
preface again because I know some people
are going to get so [__] salty I
don't want to I don't hate vtubers he
just doesn't understand I haven't gotten
into it yet and I would like to play
Devil's ADV I was exactly like this last
week just the three of us tugging our
own dicks and agreeing on something it's
not going to be a very fun
podcast I hate podcasts where they like
yeah you've got a point I agree I agree
and then I also agree then they nod
their head for two minutes I can't
[__] stand it